she actin knowing what our killer at
school that's where he made his name
ball then bleach showed us his heart
last year not only in college now he has
to be a leader he has to learn to
console guys to get fallen guys he has
to make sure that he speaks with this
actions and not just his words damn
bleep doesn't he do that all the time
poornam going in amongst the Giants the
foul for the pelicans I told coach nurse
before the game I said you have a smoker
in Radley we went through a series of
injuries Matty D is back what he talked
to his team about in the locker room he
said it's not about our execution but
our energy he said that he started the
game with very low energy been in the
paint so long playing point out of that
[ __ ] saw this definitely capable weight
reporting
and his here the torques from the crowd
siakam of a beautiful spin autolytic who
was looking for help there was no one
behind the fish heart has returned for
two wallets man lease goes his heart not
to staff at school what pace is a great
context of how to get easy buckets with
the young team and kind of be a decoy so
you can't see that the team can't play
half-court
oh man we often by the 6th was listening
to avi can make this product better and
more appealing for the fans we may even
have the referees
[Music]
those are some special fans because I
would be mad like man we're never gonna
win again without 701 for the peloton
comes right back stays confident and
happy at this time until he can get to
prove herself on the court the good job
I see Akram not forcing it but the pump
fake always work almost got to stay
vertical Darrow Cooper did just under
3:00 to go here on the forum to see a
cup Wow he hooks it back to go Saul
[Music]
we tour on toe when the Raptors are up
now check this out because the SOL is
such a good shooter he puts holiday in
the tough position how they didn't know
whether to stunt in him
or to get back at VanFleet and it's all
because the sock is spaced to floor up
there no matter what his shooting
percentage is tonight
[Music]